[Music]
I'm looking for I think we met assist by
precious my precious ring that's it
hi we're on a deck and this is first
impressions for land by ball so I go
first yeah you go first
okay jump this is what we need to do you
need to get the eggs in the pan okay
let's go oh that's it okay let's get
cold get the eggs in the pan on a stick
okay okay okay what do we do okay okay
great performance you look like a pop
star you sound like a pop star you are a
pop star you in the wings
no it's Louie wall well I don't know
where the big show we're always
available it's the beach we're on the
picture edge oh I'm next on he used to
do this there is to be used to be like
that okay but now it's like that Gus Gus
are you been shot as it shall I shot
guys I didn't like it I loved a girl
Oh Oh Princess Fiona
I got donkey what do you would you like
to see my dog cage that is actually your
best one yeah is it yes when you party
that should be a party oh that's my best
one yeah Princess Fiona really Kali
nice right
well yeah yeah are you thinking about
this this is the persons enjoy this I've
got an idea who is the driver I'm trying
to climb over a fence here by the way
it's a picture this right I wore
friend's car Lola Oh whoopsie Daisy
whoops leaves you I don't know what that
is what what is it is it Hugh Grant oh
it's your and the anticipation is
killing me me what hey a sheep hey is it
a sheep
no okay I've got no idea it what is it
was a goat Oh feed sleep well watch your
sheep do that
this is bad yeah valued now you do
brought them together and they're very
subtly different
it's a got it someone keeps [ __ ]
remembered a clue all right look at our
next guest tonight is with me with the
wobbly well well yeah oh no I don't I
don't watch these films so so I'm gonna
do my best here is this still about it
no no it's already second I stepped out
herself
okay now I'm stepping back into it are
you character that
I'm looking for a ring I think we met
assist my precious my precious ring
that's it is gone yes it is I mean you
don't deserve a point I'm looking you
never said I'm looking burning
well maybe shouldn't any phone hahaha
I'll be back
ah easy yeah I'll be back for you Sarah
Connor I'll be back so easy yeah mrs.
Brown well it's on Sports Nagar yes well
um hey you've got it I mean I couldn't
do an impression of all unfortunately or
what are you doing snack wars what I
mean he was crazy yeah Oh No welcome
back to solid did I take away now let's
cross over the scholar Moffitt who is
with some lampposts it's not me
[Laughter]
commander we count no brain dead no no
this time next year we'll all be moving
ahead the worst l boy ever her head
that's my pie piece that was freestyle